hey everyone its Johanna here as we are
heading to its summer let's bring our
fitness level up another intensity this
is a countdown challenge which I would
like you to incorporate at the end of
each workout session only three
exercises and the goal is to complete
this challenge in the shortest time
possible so you have to perform 10
repetitions of each move then 9 wraps it
wraps all the way down to 1 rep for the
final set remember to time yourself
because as you progress through the
weeks you should be able to complete
this challenge in your shortest time
possible so here are the exercises
[Music]
so let's get ready with the first
exercise super squad with overhead lips
remember this is your own personal
challenge to get your tastes and use the
weight you are comfortable with I am
using 8 kilos
ok let's go remember - you don't really
go all the way increase intensity but
you want to make sure that you are
performing proper form good six seven
eight nine ten in and out okay ten reps
one all the way in
three four five six seven eight nine ten
bicycle crunches let's go one twist two
three four five six seven eight
nine ten
ah second set nine rats set one up one
two three four five all the way down six
seven eight nine
good in and out let's go my reps one two
three four five six seven eight
naughty bicycle crunches whoa
my heart rate is going up two three four
[Music]
tweeze six seven eight nine
ah a brass super squad overhead Liz oh
one two you jump keep going
three four five
six seven eight down in and out 100x two
three four five six seven eight five two
the crunches let's go
twist two point three four five six
seven eight up seven reps keep building
it we are doing Guinea let's go zoom
squat oh we hit leave one two three four
five all the way down do not cheat six
seven good in and out
one two three four five six seven right
- no punches one twist all the way three
four five six
seven good keep going I am with you oh
I'm out of breath
six let's go down one two
beautifies three four five six down it
out six one two three four five six good
bicycle crunches six one two three drink
it four five six
very good five maps you will only get
better and up here let's get [ __ ] one
one two threes are three four five dump
in and out
one two three four five five
superconscious let's go one two three
four five good keep going guys four at
you are halfway there that's your white
all the way down do not change one I can
feel your pain two three four good down
in and out the Guinness you can just
step in
okay let's go one two bicycle crunches
four one two three four good up three
more reps three morons let's go
once done one two three down in and out
one two three good bicycle crunches do
not cheat
let's not stop now one two three
get up - rats come on two more rounds -
you're almost there this just be easier
one two
it announced let's go one two fights
those branches that's your one do not
cheat too good
one final set oh my god
I'm getting excited let's go give it
your all down one key jump down in and
out one very nice final bicycle crunches
that's yeah one and you are done just
stretch it off lengthen your body catch
your breath
so that was the countdown challenge do
record your studying time to complete
this challenge and keep track of your
time every week to see how far you have
progress and yes we want the quickest
time possible but what is more important
is for you to focus on proper techniques
so do not sacrifice proper forms just
for the sake of speeding up the workout
do let me know in the comments below
what is your stuffing time and four
weeks later let me know what is your new
quickest time to complete this challenge
all the best for new fitness food and
motivational videos please like share
and subscribe to my youtube channel and
website do follow me on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter to stay connected
with me thanks guys
[Music]
you
[Music]